because when she walked into this room
and gave her a hug that was a little too
long we warned you
yeah we were gonna hug for 10 minutes I
feel like you've chosen the right woman
and I honor that every time I see her
that's like me like respecting the
choice but also he knows that you've
always been my plan B right going on for
years and you and you should thank me
for being a shitty plan B keep it's a
pretty good plan B though it's pretty
good number one question they're healthy
he does yoga he does yoga just started
yeah I didn't know that black people do
buddy is that racial or no I didn't
because I wanna I want to listen this M
okay okay day right I don't want any
problems okay
you sure I forgot about the riots le
writers beneath us all right Bobby when
you call me today all right Natron no I
called you a chance urban Barbie you
call I go what son aah you want to do
the PAS guys you guys know I have been
busy so I go next week but then we got
them and I also want to say this you and
I are heterosexual correct I know I am
no sexual all right good
I think you are a hundred percent
straight it's just that your buttholes
game I do have a very yeah but I there's
a sexual tension between us you oh no no
no no be real that there is something
going on you know
I'm trying to be real on my podcast okay
when I see you right do I not physically
assault you yeah but you physically
assault a lot of dudes no I'm very picky
who do I physically assault you doc doc
what are they you have in common
sometimes yeah sometimes ooh I'm sure
you do leo
nah not as much not as much no it's your
Kalin no no because we cuz he does it
reciprocal which it comes back
reciprocate sit yeah you get
uncomfortable all right so you guys up
to that I like to lock you in in place
and I know that there's I know they're
sexual
yeah when you hold me I'm trying to
figure out what it is about him that I
just really love I would just say this
to uncomfortableness I think your
beloved in the comedy you know industry
and especially in stand-up that's why
that's where I'm no yin and you know Jew
over Rogen you know I mean Conan O'Brien
produced your album
you're like in the mix with a lot of
like really good camps you're also armed
a guy who like myself is crossover in
terms of like we can play white rooms
right that's we we tended play regular
rooms that everyone else plays so
there's just a lot of things about you
that I really admire but there's I just
find you sexually
yep see right there we talked about him
go to the spa all right so I take him in
the punk-rock Hobbit
hey-ya del rey oh yeah
punk rock hobbit and i go let's go to
spa Korean spa and then so they go and
like if I go to the spa with any guy
mm-hmm especially the Korean one mm-hmm
you can't make it hmm you know but this
fool and the [ __ ] punk punk rock
Hobbit were the short so I know there's
shorts here so I have to go to an area
of the spa where I know that were they
are two steps two steps I had to give it
to him and now they're in the steam room
with their [ __ ] shorts on isn't that
like against Korean spa policy it is but
they have a for whites and blacks I
guess I know what is it uncle why don't
you want me
you just exposures up to me is it listen
you've you've assaulted me in clothes no
way I'm gonna give you a shot it's not
even a small rule why was it somebody
else that doesn't know I'm gonna change
that about myself with you
[Music]